[Music]
now let me tell you some of my favorite
dishes come from food stalls around asia
and today i'm transporting you back to
that beautiful country indonesia where
honestly i learned that the best noodles
come from those street food stalls so
are you ready for a delicious asian
noodle dish in just 10 minutes oscar pan
down please
right uh beautiful noodles yeah food on
noodles um straight forward they're
already cooked simple asian greens
spring onions some beautiful little bean
sprouts bacon we're gonna render that
bacon down to get the fat out and then
use that fat to flavor this incredible
dish
my travels in indonesia one thing i did
learn is you waste nothing so watch
carefully and let's get 10 minutes on
the clock
right
uh if you've got a wok brilliant you
haven't a large frying pan
turn the gas up
we want to create some flavor so first
thing you want to do is get some bacon
this is sort of streaky lean bacon and
what i'm going to do now is render that
fat down because
there's two things going on i want the
sort of protein from the bacon but more
importantly i want the flavor from it
okay
so i'm going to cut nice
large
noodles
the
street food phenomenon in
indonesia is incredible you can actually
eat sometimes better on the street than
you can in a restaurant it's that good
start off with a little bit of oil that
helps to get the fat rendered quicker
bacon goes in okay
and the secret here is to get a bit of
texture for this dish
now my noodles are already cooked
they're blanched
so we'll be reheating them but
get some heat in there first and get
that nice crispy bacon flavor
now
the sauce
don't go too crazy on this okay because
i like it quite spicy i like it quite
sort of
acidic
but be smart on the variance especially
with the heat
in goes
the minced garlic okay
next our ginger
and that makes it a lot more fragrant
how do we get the balance right
some brown sugar
some beautiful sweet brown sugar
a little bit of
top rashi spice that gives a really nice
sort of heat and a kick to it
next a nice teaspoon of ground coriander
and then of course two parts
flip that bacon
two parts soy
okay
so literally
three tablespoons of soy sauce
and then from there
one nice tablespoon of oyster sauce give
that a really good mix okay
now the flavors in there are incredible
i like to get this sauce made up
literally two or three days before it
just sits in the fridge
again we're doing it with the noodles
over chicken and fish equally delicious
but
pandora man
look that fat now is coming out the
bacon okay i want to see
that nice crispy texture on the bacon
really important just take off the heat
for a moment
okay once that bacon starts to get
really nice and crispy
lay it nice and flat in the pan
check the seasoning okay check the
flavor
wow
that's delicious it's sharp i'm gonna
just increase that sort of soy
richness darkness in there and let it
down a little bit okay
now
yeah that's good
that's very good it's nice and thick not
too watery but
every mouthful is packed with that
wonderful asian flavor
now
bacon
once you take off the heat and let it
relax the oil starts to sort of seep out
but the crispiness that bacon stays
really nice and crisp
so eggs
always crack on a flat surface into the
pan
straight off
and
in pan down please oscar back onto the
heat but look take the tip of the whisk
and just break that up
okay
break that up
off the heat
and separate those eggs so it's almost
like a sort of fast track scrambled from
there take your noodles
and lay those noodles over those eggs
and bacon the smell is incredible
i'm telling you
now
from there we want to get a bit of
texture and color on those noodles press
them down into the eggs and the bacon so
good don't worry about breaking it up
yet
from there a little seasoned
together spice
over that'll give the heat on the
noodles okay now we go back onto the
heat
okay and start caramelizing that really
nicely
now the asian greens okay
these don't need blanched
or part boiled
just slice them nice and thinly
okay because the thinner they are the
quicker they cook and this is like a
sort of nice big
bok choy the stems are delicious the
leaves are really tasty you can hear
those noodles sort of
cracking away
once you get down to the tip
over
and then bang look
spread that out
this
is gonna send uncle roger into overdrive
trust me
now from there correct the seasoning now
i know i'm using a frying pan and he
loves the wok but
trust me i've been to indonesia more
times than he has let me tell you the
sauce
go over
and
literally just dab a touch of that sauce
in there
i'm gonna whack up the heat now okay
crank up the heat to get some flavor and
texture on there next
large spring onions again
slice
and just go at an angle okay
why
and they take on more source
and b they look great in terms of
presentation
now
hear those noodles that's what you want
honestly
lift them up
and they go in
on top
beautiful think what's at the bottom the
eggs then we had that beautiful
bacon now the noodles
and then finally some coriander
just turn that round
okay chop it once
that's the secret chop it once keep the
flavor in okay
and then finally we need some freshness
in there some bean sprouts and all you
do is literally just plant those sprouts
over there
time please
four minutes to go
whack up the heat
a touch of salt and now we start mixing
okay
beautiful
here we go
i'll give that a really good toss
and look we got just pan down please
oscar just check this out
got that crispiness in the bacon the
bacon has stuck to the noodles the
noodles stuck to the eggs and all of a
sudden it's starting to form
this beautiful street food
incredible tasty
dish now before that comes out
okay i'm going to add a touch more
flavor in there flatten it down again
nice and flat uncle roger watch
carefully from there
a touch more
sauce
fresh ginger fresh garlic
soy
now
one more toss
too much sauce you're gonna drown it
just coat those noodles so they're
lightly glazed but you don't want it
soggy
nothing worse than a soggy noodle let me
tell you
now turn that over
and now see the color please oscar pan
down pan down roger open your eyes look
beautiful
beautiful egg bacon noodles chili ginger
off
and when we come to serve
this is a dish that is
generously done the smell
is incredible
and look at that oh
nothing
goes to waste
and i just love the fact that we've got
the newly dressed beautifully it's a
generous portion and let's be honest
there's nothing there for two or three
of you
and finally finally just
just a touch
no more man
last little pickings of my cilantro
coriander depending what country you're
in
and then boom
and there we go
amazing indonesian street food
phenomenon
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsay and
10 cookbook inspired by this series and
trust me you're going to come out a much
better chef and if you like this video
don't forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck